[Music]
so
two keys huh
that's a lot of snow yeah if you can't
handle it we're happy to find someone
who can't don't worry about me friend i
can handle it marissa baby
go get our guests something to drink
would you we don't want a drink or is
this a social cup it's not a tea party i
look like five-year-old girls too
gentlemen please have some patience
cookies
pure as a catholic school girl did you
bring the cash oh we brought something
much better than cash what's that our
guns nypd you're under arrest
[Music]
boss man's gone
where'd he go
you kind little lady
gio costa you're under arrest you want
that drink now hitchcock don't mind if i
do scully don't mind if i do
hey thought i missed you hey jake
amazing assignment i have to admit
i'm a little jealous
really um well if you want i could help
you get fired i'm really good at it
yeah
this is real this is happening
look um
i don't want to be a jerk i know
you're dating teddy and it's going
really well it's just
what's going on
i don't know what's gonna happen on this
assignment and if something bad goes
down i think i'd be pissed at myself if
i didn't say this
i kind of wish something
could happen between us
romantic styles
and i know it can't because you're with
teddy and i'm going undercover and
that's
just how it is but
anyway we're
not supposed to have any contacts so i
should go
america needs me
bye
[Music]
charles
seriously no costume what the hell
charles where's your halloween spirit
but you guys always make fun of me i
have never once insulted you in my life
especially vis-a-vis your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and or thing yes i do remember
sir permission is sprint to my car and
get my emergency costume does it matter
if i say no no
[Music]
bam bam boom
what the what why are you dressed up you
look like an idiot but yeah what are you
supposed to be a sassy car mechanic no
come on he's clearly the rejected
pop-tarts mascot hairy pop-tart i am not
you know who i am squad that's enough
you're making boyle for batman purpose
he's elvis yes elvis stoico the canadian
figure skater no
squad if i could have your attention
please
being transferred to the public
relations office i'm leaving the
nine-nine effective immediately what the
hell i don't understand what the hell
why are you doing this what the hell
i want to say
it has been a pleasure to have worked
alongside all of you for the past 21 and
a half months
i'm sorry for getting so emotional
pretty consistent tone actually these
have been the
these have been the best
years of my career oh no this is new
and i know that
every one of you
give me everything you had
and i will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
me more see
dismissed
sir
i'm coming with you thank you gina i'm
also coming not necessary tell me where
the file is right now or i will ruin
jazz for you forever i'd like to see you
try wrong choice daddy-o
ah
skipper
jingle jazz
what are you gonna tell your kids man
that their daddy's a crook i don't have
any kids
my whole thing was based on you having
kids
now all of this
is going to be hypothetical
[Music]
no tools dears
all right mister
here are five stories about my cousin
leanne and her alleged lyme disease
how's that gonna make me talk
not everything's about you bob i just
needed to vent god you're such a lamb
all right listen up buddy you're gonna
tell us where it is and also what it is
we're a little unclear what we're after
sweep up sweep up in the mob
mob
aren't you supposed to be getting ready
to transfer to staten island ah that's
not real it's pretty real last week
that's before i decided to pretend it
wasn't
i'm in denial most people who were in
denial don't usually say they're in
denial that's because they're in denial
about being in denial but i'm not in
denial i'm in denial
i love you
and i'm worried about dancing in front
of our friends
the end
okay well
i've been planning this wedding for the
last six months and if you told me
yesterday everything that was gonna go
wrong
i would have had a panic attack that
sent me into the er
but i'm here
and i've never been happier
life is unpredictable
not everything's in our control but as
long as you're with the right people you
can handle anything
and you jake peralta
are the right person for me
but i do have some bad news
there is a bomb at this wedding as well
what your butt
your butt is the bomb there will be no
survivors
i love you so much you're my dream girl
i love you too
i can't wait to spend the rest of my
life with
you i was always gonna stab her in the
back you were what kind of person treats
another human being like that you
dropped me rosa and then you ship me to
new jersey first of all grow up second
of all how'd you get back here so fat if
you get a box wet enough it's very easy
to bust out of it no one ask any
follow-ups i knew i couldn't trust you
rosa that's why i was gonna double-cross
you with bill that's right he didn't
really die hey guys you really thought
i'd miss this year's heist no way i'm
part of the squad
okay this is officially getting too hard
to track who has the bracelet now
santiago yeah and none of you are
getting it we'll see about that
what the hell remember that very fancy
swiss pen i got you for christmas the
one that you keep in your pocket at all
times it's a taser bro
yeah i'll take that amy do not make me
taste you again no no don't i'm pregnant
what i just found out it's a girl oh my
god oh my god it's happening quick
someone get a reaction video of me
becoming an uncle ah she's making it up
the pregnancy scan was my idea no no no
no amy wait is that true did you just
lie to me about our baby yeah did you
lie to us about our baby you tased me
you chased me first okay now
[Music]
halloween
it's heist time
yeah i thought you could get a head
start on heist prep good luck
i'm already dressed well
i am also dressed and i made breakfast
wait where are my eggs in my belly
now get a move on it's heist time i love
halloween are you that desperate for
everyone to know how great you are it's
not about everyone okay it's just
i wanted you to know
oh my god
i got it
he's not answering any questions that's
okay i have no questions that's right
i'm about to monologue son better make
it quick you only got eight minutes all
right then let me paint you a picture
i'm phillip a successful periodontist
that's become addicted to diazepam a
sedative i take because i'm junkie scum
also for real addiction is a disease
that would be super empathetic if you
hadn't murdered a man what is the point
of this i'll get there so one day i'm
working late when my boss robert
surprises me he found out i was stealing
meds again jackie's gum also again not
your fault there's a major genetic
component to addiction he says he's
gonna file a police report i could lose
my license we fight and something in me
just snaps so i grab the first thing i
can find and i hit him with it you still
have no murder weapon i do now here's a
pick i found on yelp of the surgical
suite six months ago and here's a shot
that our crime scene photographer took
up the same room two weeks after the
murder notice any differences we're not
answering that that's all right i can
just tell you myself the yelp shot has
six of these heavy-looking glass awards
from the brooklyn periodontics society
in the background whereas this shot only
has five what happened to number six you
murdered robert with him you lost all
control and you bludgeoned him to death
there must have been blood everywhere
but you got lucky you were in the
surgical suite it can be sterilized you
never would have gotten away with it in
your carpeted office that's not what
happened don't say anything more and
your office manager would have heard all
of the screaming but she was at her
grandson's play lucky again you're wrong
you put robert's body into a wheelchair
and shoved it in the elevator it's a
miracle there wasn't blood everywhere
that's not true now you're in the garage
with a corpse you panicked and left your
phone in your office and you don't have
your car keys but roberts are in his
pocket so you put him in his car and you
take off no you can't believe what
you've done no you're flustered you have
no gps so you just start driving no
philip next thing you know you're in the
pine barrens and it hits you your
uncle's cabin he has a place there
you're the luckiest son of a wouldn't
love yes it was you got lucky at every
turn no i knew exactly where i was
driving i left my phone in the office on
purpose i was in a surgical suite by
design and i didn't use some glass award
that any idiot would clearly see was
missing i made a rod out of a special
dental polymer killed him with it and
melted it back down it's already in a
patient's mouth son
damn
oh damn oh
damn and that is 3-0 dams
oh damn
you